hey folks welcome to the dark horse
podcast live stream number 137 is it 137
137 and i
i'm gonna guess that it probably is
prime you might know better than i 137
is prime 137 is apparently a very
special number to some number of
physicists but i admit that i have only
discovered that so recently that i can't
really say much more than that there is
a
1936 paper in the journal nature called
the mysterious number 137 and a like a
companion piece i think published in the
indian journal of science about 137 and
it's
i really i i am going to stop there but
that's interesting i have always felt
like 137 is a number we can do without i
try yes i do use it occasionally but i
try to do that as little as possible
137 in particular
no
that's not true but um
i can't say that i see it as special i'm
i'm curious as to what might be special
about it other than it's it's primedness
yeah no it's uh
i shouldn't have said anything probably
no probably not because now you can't
follow through but you know i mean i
could say a few more things but i'd
probably start getting details drawing
very fast so uh so maybe we'll revisit
this next week when we will not be prime
no for sure not yeah yeah and maybe we
won't
this week however we're going to talk
about diversity equity and inclusion
whether or not it belongs in science
wonderful you uh might imagine how we
feel about that how do we heal and how
does illness affect our perception of
same
and land sharks
yeah man land sharks yeah i think i mean
that's that that's basically all all
you've told me
no no it's it's land sharks
yeah
excellent we're going to save land
sharks for last
i mean of course obviously it's very
beautiful
keep people
tuning in if they are they are weary of
the diversity equity inclusion
discussion yes tuna
i'm no different
uh well i mean in this case the sharks
are unlikely to eat tuna although
presumably tuna start very small but
true and also tuna and sharks actually
have a convergent form of being sort of
very streamlined for speed as top
predators of open ocean hunting
right so it's sort of a badass
coefficient
causes a change in the morphology to
facilitate the
rapid wiggle waggle towards the edible
things
badass coefficient rapid wiggle waggle
edible things that was that was the
those were the key terms that i got from
the most professional sentences i've
ever written great that was great you
know that works they work in a pen
yes and you don't want to be pinched by
either a tuna or a shark or a landshark
or a goose buy a goose whatever yeah all
these things to be avoided if possible
you know you just keep maybe it's us we
scared the dog away
at the point your labrador goes grows
weary of you you know you've done
something wrong right that's true yeah
that is true yeah
all right should we uh do some uh sort
of logistics and then embark
pay the rent and then we uh
head right for it indeed
uh we follow these live streams the q a
and we will do so this week you can ask
questions at darkhorsesubmissions.com
and we'll get to as many of them as we
can we start that about 15 minutes after
the end of this main episode
we of course have our hunt together's
guide to the 21st century out now in
english french and spanish and this
month is coming out in a few new places
in the spanish edition in latin america
and i i forgot to look it's either in
august or in september that it got and
the spanish edition is coming into the
us as well
which we're pretty excited about uh we
are live on youtube and odyssey and the
in this the chat is live on odyssey
we've got a new store at
darkhorsedoor.org
home
uh you could check out
my weekly ish writings at
naturalselections.substantial
this week i
i wrote a short piece that got a lot of
positive attention
which i think i titled you were not
alone
about
what many people are feeling
right now going against what we are told
is the only legitimate opinion to have
in a number of areas um uh although i
was specifically responding to a number
of correspondents who are writing that
they're losing friends some have lost
jobs
some are losing touch with family over
their position
as to how to stay healthy during this
particular pandemic that we seem to be
at risk of finding ourselves in
permanently given how the public health
response
is bad is ben
is better like
has and continues to been
exactly yes
um
and we are supported by by you uh so we
appreciate you subscribing to this
channel the darkhorse podcast clips
channel on youtube on odyssey
liking sharing as as widely as you can
subscribing and notifying of course
subscribing and notifying yourself of
the fact you've subscribed clicking the
notification
bell there you go
and um
and we appreciate we appreciate all of
that and we appreciate uh
any any sharing of what we're doing with
with anyone else and of course if you
can afford to we appreciate financial
support as well you can join us at our
patreons where it's going to be having a
conversation tomorrow on his patreon on
the last sunday of the month we do
private q as associated with mine
and you can also access the discord
server which is a lively community of
people who do not cancel you for your
thoughts even if you are the only one
who has them uh in in the discord serv
discord server community yes uh and they
do karaoke they do
they do book clubs they do lots of
virtual happy hours lots of lots of
great stuff there so you can you can
find that at either of our patreons and
of course uh we have sponsors we were we
were really reluctant to start to have
to have sponsors and we we held off for
a long time we've got just this this
fabulous
um
ad broker uh and um
and our moderator and um our assistant
who who compelled us to start working
with sponsors and we've been very very
grateful to have done so we are very
choosy we only take sponsors uh who have
products or services that we can truly
vouch for or have someone close to us
who can vouch for them and so uh with
with no further ado we have three this
week as is our want and we will start so
our first sponsor this week is seed
seed is a company focused on bacteria
and the microbiome and they have a
terrific probiotic called ds01 daily
synthiotic
there are a lot of things that you can
do to enhance your health our sign off
here at darkhorse includes three of them
be good to the ones you love eat good
food and get outside but a lot is hidden
in those words what for instance
constitutes good food
well good food is real food whole food
food that has been alive recently and
was grown with care and conditions as
ancient as possible given the
constraints of the 21st century but even
many people who eat such a diet are
missing something
we contain multitudes
every individual human contains so many
other organisms some of which may harm
us but many of which exist with us in
harmony we need them this is why
probiotics can be an important tool in a
healthy lifestyle even if you eat
nutrient-dense food and avoid processed
foods and sugar
that said probiotics are kind of the new
current thing everyone's taking them or
thinking of taking them it can seem like
maybe it's just a fad good news though
seeds ds01 daily symbiotic is the real
deal not all probiotics are created
equally
seeds ds01 daily symbiotics are broad
spectrum 2 in 1 probiotic and prebiotic
it contains 24 distinct probiotic
strains and a two in one capsule which
protects the probiotics until they hit
the colon where they are most effective
if you've taken a probiotic before and
never felt a difference it's likely
because the good bacteria weren't
surviving your gi tract seed is designed
differently that's why it works
seeds daily synbiotics supports gut skin
and heart health and micronutrient
synthesis many of you who have used seed
report improvements to digestive
function in 24 to 48 hours i actually
just received a testimonial from a dark
horse
fan
who took seed following one of our
previous ads for them and has seen
remarkable remarkable effects
start a new healthy habit today visit
seed.com darkhorse and use code
darkhorse to redeem 20 off your first
month of seeds ds01 daily symbiotic
that's seed.com.com
darkhorse and use code darkhorse
our second amazing sponsor this week is
vevo barefoot shoes made for feet
most shoes are made for someone's idea
of what feet should be vivos however are
made by people who actually know feet
here at darkhorse we love these shoes
they are beyond comfortable the tactile
feedback from the surfaces you're
walking on is amazing they cause no pain
because there are no pressure points
forcing your feet into odd positions
they're really fantastic
our feet of course are the products of
millions of years of evolution as is all
of us
humans evolved to walk move and run
barefoot but modern shoes that are
overly cushioned and strangely shaped
have negatively impacted food function
and are contributing to a health crisis
one in which people move less than they
might in part because their shoes make
their feet hurt
vivo barefoot shoes are designed wide to
provide natural stability thin to enable
you to feel more and flexible to help
you build your natural strength from the
ground up foot strength increases by 60
in a matter of months just by walking
around in them
the number of people wearing vivo
barefoots is growing once people start
wearing these shoes they don't seem to
stop
vivo barefoot has a great range of
footwear for kids and adults and for
every activity from hiking to training
and everyday wear they're certified b
corp pioneering regenerative business
principles and their footwear is
produced using sustainably sourced
natural and recycled materials with the
aim to protect the natural world so you
can run wild in it go to
vivobarefoot.com darkhorse to get an
exclusive offer of 20 off additionally
all new customers get a 100 day free
trial so you can see if you love them as
much as we do that's
v-i-v-o-b-a-r-e-f-o-o-t
dot com slash darkhorse i have been
appreciating my vivos even more with the
summer weather as we range farther the
feel that you get on all those different
substrates is so cool totally
all right our final sponsor today is
public goods public goods is a one-stop
shop for everyday essentials the
ingredients are carefully sourced high
quality and affordable you can simplify
your life by getting your necessities at
public goods public goods has coffee and
tea grains and oils like olive and
avocado they've also got castile soap
and trash bags and laundry detergent
they have spices and extracts vinegars
and hot sauces dishware and glassware
public goods has everything you need to
make a meal including the materials to
serve it on
public goods searches the globe to find
clean healthy eco-friendly and
innovative products
public goods cares about health and
sustainability their products are
largely free of harmful ingredients and
additives and their ingredients are
ethically sourced rather than buying
from
buying a bunch of
single product brands public goods
members can buy all of their premium
essentials in one place with one
beautiful simpline
simple streamlined aesthetic and their
subscription service is efficient and
simple and easy to use public goods
members can buy all their premium
essentials in one place it really is an
everything store
for dark horse listeners we have the
following offer receive 15 off your
first public goods order with no minimum
purchase they are so confident that you
will absolutely love their products and
come back again and again that they are
giving you fifteen dollars to spend on
your first purchase go to
publicgoods.com
darkhorse or use the code darkhorse at
checkout
that's p u b l i c g o o d s dot com
forward slash dark horse to receive 15
off your first order
[Music]
all right all right
let us start
talking about the ei diversity equity
and inclusion
somebody's favorite topic i imagine yeah
i am a fan of all three of those things
by the way uh even equity
yeah
the original uh flavor though equity
which they have borrowed and turned into
a very ironic term as they have with all
of these things but yeah i believe that
there will you know it's rather like the
term woke that there uh was an original
meaning that was very very high quality
it did have subtlety and nuance to it
and of course that nuance was the
gateway through which the hijacking took
place
anyway so i didn't mean to derail you
but yes i am you know i'm also you know
what matters black lives i've always
believed that right but again it's in
the fine print which you find out when
you pursue these slogans woke the
uh diversity equity and inclusion yeah
and uh well as you know
you had a particularly pithy way of
describing the problem this is from
before you know when we were still
more or less happily and we thought
comfortably
a tenured at evergreen uh that
the you know the the wrapping on the box
the label on the box is not a match for
the contents and this is of course it's
a great publicity stunt all you have to
do apparently to confuse a lot of people
is to stick a label on a thing and you
can convince them that uh that the
trojan horse is indeed a horse
there's a lot of mixed things there but
no no the label on the box doesn't fit
the contents is exactly what's going on
and you know at some point we're going
to get wise to this ploy
yeah and you know
it's
a lot of a lot of people a lot of people
are confused so we talked you know we've
of course uh talked a fair bit about
intrusions into academia and into
science in particular
via this this route having been
you know run off of our own campus now
five plus years ago
and
in june of 2021 in livestream 84 where
we were also talking about george
orwell's book 1984
we
discussed uh dr anna krylov's excellent
article which was also published that
month june of 2021
um it's called the peril of politicizing
science and
here it is you can show
my screen here this was
the piece that we discussed again
13 months ago published in the journal
of physical chemistry letters and this
is actually the very same version that i
highlighted for our discussion 13 months
ago so i've got my highlights here let
me just she starts
with
a quote from george orwell
in which he says it's a beautiful thing
the destruction of words don't you see
that the whole aim of newspeak is to
narrow the range of thought in the end
we shall make thought crime literally
impossible because there will be no
words in which to express it
and i'm just going to scroll to one of
the things that i highlighted when we
were talking about this last time
which is this paragraph here
the answer is simple our future is at
stake as a community we face an
important choice we can succumb to
extreme left ideology and spend the rest
of our lives ghost chasing and witch
hunting rewriting history politicizing
science redefining elements of language
and turning stem science technology
engineering mathematics education into a
farce
or we can uphold a key principle of
democratic society the free and
uncensored exchange of ideas and
continue our core mission the pursuit of
truth focusing attention on solving real
important problems of humankind
now dr karloff who i have now been
fortunate enough to meet and talk with
and she is fantastic
she's also a gen xer like ourselves but
um you know unlike ourselves was born
into the soviet union and so grew up in
a totalitarian regime and so knows where
if she speaks specifically when she
compares what she is seeing
um in the movement to to censor and to
cancel and to shut down dissent and
argument to what she saw under living
under soviet rule uh for the first few
decades i think
of her life
so this is an excellent piece i highly
recommend it we talked about it a lot in
episode 84
which is um
which is up on odyssey i think this was
the first time that we were concerned
that youtube was going to actively shut
us down and so uh i don't think they
took it off uh youtube but it is not
available on youtube interestingly the
episode in which we talk about um
censorship one of the episodes in which
we talk about censorship and and orwell
is only up on odyssey but it is there
yep you're gonna see something oh
um
so
she
she actually she's a she's a professor
she's a chemist at usc and usc actually
gave her uh
its award for science communication let
me see if i can find this
uh
yeah here we go you can again if you
like show my screen here zach uh
inaugural since this is the first year
that they that usc was offering the
communicator of the year award
to honor scholars who engaged with the
public
and um
this is
uh this is a picture of of the winners
from the various divisions at the
university
who received this uh this and if you
scroll down and look at what they have
to say about anna um communicator of the
year in natural sciences and mathematics
they
celebrate her
for starting a conversation or you know
at least beginning a conversation in
many circles where a lot of us have been
talking and she was certainly talking
before she wrote this piece
in a way that got the attention of more
people and so you know kudos to the
university of southern california for
recognizing her frankly bravery for
stepping into the fray and saying
actually this is not what science is
this is not how science works and
remarkable that she should actually be
literally awarded you know rewarded for
having done so you have something to add
here i will when you get to the end of
this thought no you go for it well i
just want to uh no i think it requires
you to continue the story i just wanted
to not forget okay okay
um
so
all of that is
for the good
we have
conversation we have a scientific
journal that has published a piece by an
eminent chemist a practicing chemist
that says
the madness must stop we must actually
have science as science is done and not
have it be impinged upon and infringed
upon by by ideology and politics and she
speaks from a position of some personal
authority having observed what that
looks like uh in what it looked like in
the soviet union when that happened and
we see the university where she is
tenured uh actually i believe uh
actually celebrating her for that that's
terrific however
now
uh
in the same journal that published that
piece
we have
see sorry about this
we have a new piece in again the journal
of physical chemistry letters you know
kudos to the journal for publishing uh a
what is effectively a rebuttal although
it's 13 months later so it's not exactly
a rebuttal but it is a de facto a
rebuttal to krylov's work it is called
words matter on the debate over free
speech inclusivity and academic
excellence
and if you look i'm not going to read
the whole thing aloud here but if you
look at who they appear to be
that's not good um
who they appear to be
responding to who they cite it's
krylov's original piece and two pieces
that she has published since then with
some other co-authors so it really does
seem to be a response and kind and these
are um also you know other chemists
let's just start with the first two
paragraphs from this piece again uh
published
i think it's july i think it's last
month in the same journal journal of
physical chemistry letters what do we
value as an academic in a scientific
community they ask
do our core values include only the
pursuit of facts and inventions to the
exclusion of other considerations
or do we accept that scientists have a
responsibility to serve society beyond
simply expanding the knowledge base and
should therefore concern themselves at
least in part with how their words and
actions intersect and impact the human
sphere
a science a scientist's innovations
might be profound benefiting many but if
that person's words or actions create an
alienating or hostile workplace or
learning environment then how should the
scientific community evaluate that
person's overall contribution to
humanity
how should society view such a person
these questions lie at the heart of an
emerging conversation regarding what
equality means for the greater
scientific enterprise as we pursue
increased diversity and inclusion of
underrepresented groups at our
universities
so i have a number of little excerpts to
share from this
but
i know you have something to say here
let me just comment on this particular
excerpt first
right off the bat here they have created
a straw man
the idea
that
dr krylov is interested
or it doesn't care
doesn't has has not a care for the
creation of an alienating or hostile
work environment
is
patently false
and it is a straw man position which
once you hear that if you imagine that
these people who are scientists and
therefore should know something about
what a complete solution set of
hypotheses on the table looks like
if you hear this and you take it to be
well there's two positions and obviously
i don't like the idea of a hostile work
environment and if you're saying that's
fine with you then i'm in the other camp
i'm on the other side
and
that's not what
this that's not what the landscape
actually looks like right it is it has
never looked like that and
one of the ways that that is a false
representation of what those of us who
are resisting diversity equity inclusion
measures are saying is that your
measures
are actually making the problem worse
many of us can see that there certainly
has been and to some degree remains
problems with
systemic racism sexism etc but the idea
that believing anyone's feelings as soon
as they speak them out loud and that
trusting those feelings to be
representative of what needs to happen
in order to make it better
is the way to make a more diverse
equitable and inclusive society is for
most of us who are speaking out about it
and have thought about it carefully
exactly the opposite of what you should
be doing
so the straw man is not just a straw man
it's actually the opposite of what is
true in many regards yeah it's the it's
the inverse of right yeah which uh
increasingly the inverse of right is
something that we have to watch for any
time you see it it's an indicator that
some process is a foot that is not the
one that is being described yes um i
would point out a couple things one
i
have come to detest awards
and the reason that i've come to detest
awards is that they always get hijacked
right the purpose of awards at least in
principle is a noble one the idea is you
want to take something like dr krylov's
courageous point
and you want to add a benefit to having
made it especially one that's unexpected
that then will embolden such a person to
continue to do such a thing and will
show others hey this might be a scary
thing to say out loud but it does get
noticed and it gets noticed in a way
that's actually something you can put on
your cv yeah right so the potential
benefit to awards is huge as the benefit
to something like tenure that protects a
person who has contributed at a certain
level so that they can be free to say
uncomfortable difficult things
but what happens to these things is they
are equally useful as a mechanism for
emboldening those who shouldn't be
emboldened
and
so anyway
in this case it sounds like
usc gave a proper award this isn't a
case of the corruption but i will say
that the flip side of this predicts the
story here
the flip side
of the award situation
is
spite
and
we're going to get to the technical
definition here in a second but the
point is when somebody like dr krylov
makes a point like this one in a way
that is then recognized by her
university
then the danger she poses to the false
uh whatever the contents of the box
label diversity equity and inclusion is
the threat she poses is that much
greater that's what the award is for
right the award is for speaking uh truth
to some kind of cryptic illegitimate
power
and so the cryptic illegitimate power
and a prompt conversation right to
prompt conversation to defuse the bomb
right to the extent that this bomb
allows but even if she were wrong that's
what i'm saying right like but but maybe
maybe she's not in this case but even if
she were wrong and what it does is
prompt conversation and allows for a
greater understanding of the basis on
which the original communication were
wrong that that is worthy of of high
notice as well because that is what we
are trying to do is we discuss in order
to discover
and the the folks who are engaged in
this illegitimate revolution know that
what they have to do is make
conversation impossible right here are
the things you have to believe and
conversation about whether that's the
things that you really do have to
believe has to become impossible those
are the two necessary things so to the
extent that somebody steps in and says
actually i can discuss these things
right i'm not afraid to discuss race i'm
not afraid to discuss
gender right i'm not afraid to discuss
history and what our obligations based
on it are that person is an extra threat
and so now we get to this question of
what spite is spite is something that
has been carefully considered inside
evolutionary biology
and the basic point is spite
is the acceptance of a cost in order to
inflict a cost
right
and that may sound bizarre right why are
you interested in inflicting costs and
why would you accept a cost that sounds
like just it's all bad right and it is
inside the matrix of
costs and benefits why would you accept
a cost to inflict a cost because the
cost to you of not doing so is larger in
the long term now this makes a lot more
sense if you think in terms of lineages
but if you have a person who is
profiting by doing bad things
it may be expensive
to make it difficult for them to
continue
that's i'm going to accept a cost in
order to inflict a cost policing is the
acceptance of a cost we in civilization
pay to have police what police do is
they drive up the cost of committing
crimes right so what we want is for
crime not to pay if crime doesn't pay we
won't see it and how do you make crime
pay well you have a certain number of
people paid to find the criminals and
make sure that they are punished and it
doesn't have to be 100 it just has to be
enough that engaging in crime is not a
wise thing to do right so the point is
when somebody like dr krylov steps into
the fray and says actually based on what
i've seen i know what we need to be
talking about and i'm going to show you
that it can be done
the necessity for those engaged in this
illegitimate revolution to punish her is
going to be uh
obvious and so at some level this this
newest uh this newest
article uh was inevitable something was
certainly going to fill that space and
that it happens to be an article that it
happens to have been written by the
people it was written by who knows
whatever the point is it could have been
anything but what must not stand is oh
she said this daring thing and then got
an award maybe we should say daring
things maybe we'll get awards right that
can't stand so you can expect that there
will be somebody is going to come up
with something to rob that award of its
power to make this behavior more comp
um so
yes so i would argue
that trajectory is inevitable
the particulars are not but this is
exactly what happened to us too
right because we had a community of
people because it was uh diverse in
every regard right we had trans people
in our community at evergreen we're
talking about our students we're
professors yep we had trans people we
had people of many different races we
had
wide economic diversity amongst our
students and they were all thrilled to
be doing what we were doing together and
so that was a danger to the story that
evergreen had a terrible problem with
white supremacy that it was impossible
for students of color to get a decent
education blah blah blah blah blah we
had to be punished and we were so i
would just say yep we need to zoom out
and notice that transition somebody
shows it can be done somebody has to
punish them for doing so fascinating
yeah
okay let me read another small section
from this uh just published
article
again by
sorry i've forgotten the name it's um
herbert at all in the journal of
physical chemistry letters unnaming the
buildings this two paragraph section is
called recently four buildings at the
university of california berkeley were
were unnamed following a substantive and
transparent process that acknowledged
both the eponymous individuals
contributions to their disciplines and
to the university but also their
considerable flaws
in each of these four cases it was
ultimately concluded that the latter
outweigh the former and that the
individuals in question can no longer be
viewed as exemplifying the values that
the university seeks to champion
for example a building formerly known as
leconte hall was a historical honour
bestowed in recognition of john leconte
berkeley's first faculty member and its
first acting president yet lacant was
also known as a virulent racist
other institutions are also undertaking
the difficult but necessary work to
recognize the implications and
significance of honorific building names
our values our priorities and our biases
are reflected in those we choose to
honor and our community sends a message
about institutional values when it
renames or unnames a lecture an award or
a building
this is not cancelling but rather
recalibrating
institutions and institutional values
evolve over time and the people who
those institutions choose to exalt
should evolve in tandem we need to
consider our appellations wisely aiming
for enduring values and acknowledging
that decisions made in the past may no
longer reflect who we are or who we
aspire to be as a scientific and an
academic community
let me read the choices sentence one
more time italics in the original this
is not canceling but rather
recalibrating
yes that is now if that doesn't sound
totalitarian and new speaky i don't know
what does
yeah it's another term where
a term that we used to be able to use
that was highly effective for which
there is no obvious synonym right is now
compromised by the fact that it is going
to be used as a weapon and so you know
well and you can't i mean obviously
things need calibrating right you know
that we're scientists we know that we
got to recalibrate our stuff every now
and then so sometimes our names need to
be recalibrated recalibrating yeah um
it's clever i mean i'll give them that
yeah no stupid they're not
um
they
i'll just read a few more things and
first riff on they say uh in the next
section yeah they say in the next
section here about a number of journals
and i'm not going to go into the
background of exactly which journals are
talking about but these journals do not
censor new science or scientific
disagreements unless remain aligned with
their primary purpose
now on what basis are they claiming that
journals do not censor new science or
scientific disagreements
they have no basis and in fact they tell
a story in here about a paper having
been they say uh retracted and in fact
they're they're misspeaking and i'm not
going to go into to that story here but
they are being they're playing very fast
and loose with both you know immediate
past history but also
presumably knowingly
are alighting truth at best by saying
these journals do not censor new science
or scientific disagreements
now you know what
what
could you call
an editorial decision to publish this
and not that a form of censorship even
if it really was not
you could and you might be wrong right
so there is going to be gray area where
actually that's not what our journal
does or that's not within the purview of
you know that's not within the scope of
this journal is a completely legitimate
thing for a journal to uh to to say
and that does not make what that journal
is engaging in censorship but we also
know we have seen especially in these
last two years
through through covet to closing in on
two and a half now gosh yeah um
how many times articles have actually
either been on route to publication
having gone through peer review
successfully
or even having been published and then
they're then they're retracted
and that
actively looks like censorship yeah i
mean it clearly is censorship right um
for those who want an example the
mccullough and rose paper which had
passed peer review was headed to
publication and then suddenly was
unpublished by yeah
the publisher is a great one and i'm not
like a in that case i i'm not sure
retracted is technically the right term
but you know at some level it doesn't
matter what happened
you know they played by all the rules
that you know we in science are supposed
to play by when we're trying to get
published and those rules are
increasingly stacked against
those who speak truth that doesn't match
what the mainstream narrative says
despite that and despite the fact that
what they were writing about did not
match the mainstream narrative they got
through it
but then they didn't then they got
sidelined so
if you go back to that sentence that you
read that basically says papers are not
being censored by journals yep
that is again they're talking about
particular journals but yeah it is a
totally predictable that argument is
necessary right it has to be made it has
no information untestable right the
basic point is look if it were true that
there were censorship and then you could
say well
there's a bunch of censorship
we're not in favor of scientific
censorship we don't like censorship
right so the point is well no there has
to be an argument that rolls its eyes
and says there is no censorship it's not
censorship right that will be there no
matter what it would be there if it were
true it'd be there if it's false it's a
non-informational sentence there it is
but
it does begin to point
so the thing about orwell that always
troubled me that now doesn't trouble me
at all having lived through the last few
years
is that it was too stark to be real
the inversion of language was cartoonish
it was absurd yeah and i thought he's
making a point
by overdrawing and that's a little
unfortunate and now i'm it's like no i'm
watching the complete inversion of
reality he was telling us what was going
to happen and it was impossible to see
if you hadn't lived it which is part of
why people from the soviet union and
elsewhere have contacted us and said uh
you should know what that is you're
seeing we've seen it before yeah um
so in some sense yes it can happen here
is is one of the things we hear right
and i'm you know and this is another
thing people have said to us so many
times
they've heard our story our personal
story
and they were polite and quiet about it
they assumed we must be exaggerating
maybe that's not the worst human fault
and then they encounter it and they
contact us and they say whoa
you weren't exaggerating if anything you
were downplaying it which we were
because we were trying to be cautious
yeah um so i guess
the
rather complete vindication of orwell is
an amazing fact and here you're seeing
it in real time in a scientific context
indeed
okay a couple more couple more sections
from this
this new paper
on faculty hiring they say we note with
dismay that hiring of black faculty at
colleges and universities in the united
states has actually decreased in recent
years
at the current rate the percentage of
black faculty will not reach parity with
the percentage of black americans within
our lifetimes
so
in the current cultural climate i don't
they i didn't go and look at their
references so i don't know i i don't
know if it's true but they're claiming i
don't know if the stats are good
and i don't know what recent years
refers to
but
if these authors are actually claiming
that in the last
certainly 10 but i would say 20 years
that there is
active
racial bias
against faculty of color
i cry foul i find this
i find this to be
absurd
and
what
we do know
is that in
for instance historically black
neighborhoods
there are economic disadvantages that
persist to this day so we have
everything from food deserts to poor
educational opportunities
and
maybe if we actually care the way that
so many people are willing to say they
care by putting stickers on their
windows and such
we should consider
increasing the quality of the science
education in the schools in historically
black neighborhoods
this this it seems to me would do a
better job of increasing the pool of
people who are interested in and
qualified to become faculty in the
sciences for instance than in enforcing
a
i mean they don't even they don't even
have a
plan here but what they seem to be
saying is what we need is to
uh
to in to enact affirmative action at the
faculty hiring level in order to get um
the racial makeup of our faculty to
match the racial makeup of the country
i think you're being too gentle and i
will say
i i aspire to live in a world in which
roughly speaking it won't be precise but
there is parity between the racial
makeup of society and the racial makeup
of academic faculties and the racial
makeup of boardrooms and all of that a
healthy society would produce that in
general on average and we don't have
that but for various different reasons
but whatever you said there isn't
th that parody doesn't exist yes it just
sounded like you said there is no no
okay a world that functioned really
really well in which your race might be
an interesting fact about you but didn't
predict your success or
anything like that it would do that in
general you would see that kind of thing
and if the public schools look like the
communities that they're in
shouldn't the industries in a society
look like the society that they're in it
would be cool you know if opportunities
were equally distributed and
people
had the ability to generate interests
that just simply you know were passions
that they followed they would end up in
these roles in rough
proportion to their prevalence in
society that'd be great
however there's a much better
explanation here for why this isn't
happening right and i'm sorry but
at this moment
there's almost got to be something wrong
with you to go into academia
no there does you have to be missing
what i didn't see that coming i mean i
know that's what you believe i just
didn't see that coming right but okay
especially in the sciences
let's suppose you're passionate about
seeking the truth you're really going to
enter an environment that's being
overrun by zealots who believe who wrote
whatever that freaking sentence was
about the obligation of scientists
right now we're going to come back to
that in a second here but uh the
obligation oh the um
basically they made some argument about
are we really going to allow people to
make scientific discoveries and not pay
any attention to their moral failings or
whatever yep crazy version of the
argument
um and you know again i want to come
back to that because there is a proper
argument to be rescued from it but what
they've done is another straw man
but in any case i would point out
something that we noticed in all of the
mentoring we did of all of the students
who passed through our classrooms while
we were professors
there were a couple groups of people
that were particularly unlikely to go
into academia right what i saw were
which for us meant academic science
because that's what we were teaching
children of immigrants
and
uh minority children who had or they
weren't children at the point they
reached us but people who had grown up
with some sort of adversity and had made
it to college right now the reason was
perfectly apparent in talking to them
which is in a family that has struggled
right if you start talking about oh i
want to go into women's studies right
somebody hold on but that's that's a
strong man i'm i'm gonna come back to it
i'm just trying to make the point about
how this works let's say it was as bad
as mom dad i'm thinking of going into
women's studies somebody grabs you by
the lapels and says look
the fact is this isn't just about you
there isn't a future in that thing and
what you should go into is something
where there's potential
right now the academic sciences were
better
i'm not sure they are better now right
because the only opportunity that exists
in science the real opportunity comes
from insight and if insight is now going
to be filtered through some evaluation
of your moral quality and whether or not
you take the right positions on
men choosing to be women or whatever it
is right then the point is well there's
no opportunity there either so not only
are you choosing an academically
hobbled environment where the upside of
being a scientific academic is low to
begin with your likelihood of surviving
is low because there are way too few
jobs for the number of phds produced for
reasons we've talked about it other
times so the point is you're going into
a dead end path now
you'd be better off
becoming a doctor or a nurse or learning
to code or whatever it is and so the
point is families that have struggled
often have kids who are directed i know
how i'm going to make my way in the
world they're much more economically
focused and so to the extent that such
people might look at the opportunities
of joining the professor it with some
sort of skepticism that's partially on
the professor for not providing an
environment that makes any sense it's
absolutely true and i think i've said
this on dark horse before but i actually
had
uh more than one conversation about
in which this was explicit back when we
were at michigan when uh when we were in
grad school and i was a ta and you know
we we both ta'ed for i think 10
semesters there and
we got you know we get some some higher
level stuff but we both did a couple of
terms of the intro bio series where
which was one of the weed out courses
for the pre-health including pre-med
pre-dental pre-nursing all of it and
very very low percentage of the students
who are actually interested or saying at
that point i want to go into science i
want to become a scientist they would
say i want to be a doctor or i want to
be a dentist i want to be a nurse but i
ended up talking at one point to um in
one class
labs are wonderful teaching labs are
wonderful in part because they give
opportunity for small discussions that
can can go on for a fair bit of time
it's sort of like field trips and so um
i ended up as i remember it talking with
two or three young men african-american
men
who had not come from a lot of money but
also you know they weren't they weren't
upper middle class uh by you know by
their backgrounds but they they weren't
desperately poor um but their families
didn't have much
and
they were
you know it's been a lot of years so i
don't i don't remember the specifics and
i may be you know combining some some
individuals here
but you know they had a lot of potential
and i was talking to them about what
their what their plans were and one of
them said to me and the other or others
concurred rapidly look i love the
science i love what we're doing in this
class
but there's no there's no chance i'm
going into science because i need to be
able to provide not just for me but for
my family in order to keep us moving in
the economic trajectory that um i am
helping us move now and you know that
this is now changing too of course but
at that point in the 90s uh when we were
grad students
uh it looked like becoming a doctor was
a secure financial move and becoming a
professor really wasn't yeah what are
you going to do there and also there's
no guarantee the way that you know if
you are if you are smart and work hard
uh and could get through medical school
there was going to be demand for you you
weren't going to be knocking on doors
looking to for a place to hang up your
shingle right uh and in fact we did not
recommend it wasn't like these arguments
were made and we were like no come on
you should go pursue a phd the fact is
it would have been irresponsible to
advise most students to do it even the
ones maybe even in some cases especially
the ones
who were
unusually gifted in our field yeah right
do you really you know
what i did and what i assume you did
was sat down with them and gave them a
very frank
uh view of what it looks like and the
answer is okay
you're good at evolutionary biology
are you good at the kinds of things you
will need to be good at to get through
grad school because those are very
different things right
are you gonna be able to do it are you
gonna be able to put up with the years
of trying to get into a secure position
what's going to happen if you end up
exploited as an adjunct or a lecturer or
whatever else
so many people are right and so the fact
is some of some of and i
i don't mean favorite uh in any sense
but one does look at a student who has
an unusual gift for the field that means
so much to you
and yes you would love to have them
follow in your footsteps but at some
level the advice was no no no take that
gift that you have and point it at
something where you might be rewarded
for it was much better advice indeed
um
i want to say one more thing before we
move on
your point about where you cried foul
right this point about well we're not
hiring uh minority faculty uh the rate
is dropping yeah that may be the case
for reasons you and i have both
described reasons that that might be the
case that has nothing to do with racism
right
now my point would be we've lived inside
the academy
this is this just like the example i use
of the bike shop right
black bicyclists are less common than
you that you would expect based on the
percentage of black people in the
population
is that because the bike store is
reluctant to sell bikes to black people
hell no it's the absolute opposite right
you would find that environment very
welcoming right
it's other things it's whether the roads
that you grew up around were hospitable
to bikers or they were too dangerous to
contemplate it who knows it could be
could be a lot of things but
there's something to the idea of um role
models who remind you of yourself and so
you know this is one of the things that
some on the right who decry diversity
equity and inclusion uh take aim at like
ah you don't you know you don't need
role models that look like you it's like
you don't need them
but having stories in which
uh people who are doing things that you
now aspire to remind you a little bit of
yourself do make it easier for a child
to imagine themselves attaining that
right and so and so you know if you
never see anyone on a bike if the only
time you see a bike is when you watch
some hollywood movie and it's always
white characters maybe it just feels
like that's not something that people
like me do yeah or it's always a bmx
bike and so it doesn't seem like a thing
adults do or whatever but the point is
if you stood by the the bike lane
and you you know
counted people from different
backgrounds as they went by and then
concluded it must be racism keeping
people out of the bike lane you'd be
wrong it's other processes and the point
not that that claim hasn't been made
right oh the claim is made and you know
i'm not ruling out the possibility that
it does play a role somewhere is there
racism in the tour de france i don't
know maybe but um
but
the point is in the academy is it
plausible that racism is causing people
to hire
white folks over equally qualified
minority minority candidates it's so
disastrous
it's preposterous it would be so far in
the opposite direction based on the
culture of the academy
that it is not only a place to cry foul
but it is simply impossible that that's
the causal mechanism here that's right
so i got two more uh bits from this
paper and then a little a little
just post-amble a word
post amble
might have to be done walking i think
yeah yeah yeah a parabulatory post amble
yes something
um
these guys herbert at all 2022 actually
make a point that i agree with in this
paper believe it or not they say
many of the metrics traditionally used
to define excellence such as hailing
from elite institutions are proxies with
considerable inherent
bias yes they are
yes they are and i don't i actually did
not look into the
the histories of the authors of this
piece i don't know if they came from
elite institutions but it's absolutely
true and elite institutions means
something slightly different in each
field you know there are always
universities in every field that are you
know top ten for for that field that
maybe as an outsider you wouldn't
inherently
intuit but
many of the metrics traditionally used
to define excellent such as hailing from
elite institutions are proxies with
considerable inherent bias this is
absolutely true and it's part of why we
rail against
not just elitism but the institutions
who
basically prize themselves on being
elite and on the very idea of being
elite in part also
because
what we saw
again at evergreen which was
we loved it i'm i'm not i'm saying this
with love for the institution as it was
maybe the opposite of an elite
institution
if one of the measures by which you
would assess whether an institution is
elite is
the acceptance rate of the applicants
right so evergreen
basically accepted every single person
who applied it had something above a 99
acceptance rate and most people who
heard that number assumed that evergreen
was ashamed of it and really trying to
get that number down because isn't
everyone isn't the number of people you
turn away a sign of how amazing you are
and
there is
some
truth sometimes in that assessment but
what we found
was that this allowed people to sort
once they were there and did that mean
that a lot more people
walked away
yeah i think it did because evergreen
was quite unique and
it wasn't for everyone and everyone
wasn't for it so even though it took
most comers
a lot of people decided after arriving
there that it wasn't the right fit and
unfortunately there was a whole lot of
grift and graft there and so you could
find some program some faculty who would
just basically help you get a degree if
you didn't do anything
but at least in the sciences at least in
some parts of the sciences there for a
long time it was possible to do
extraordinarily high quality work
even if and we would argue in some cases
maybe especially if your experience
up until that point academically was one
of being told you're not good enough
you're not smart enough oh you've got
adhd you've got anxiety you should need
to be on pharmaceutical drugs you can't
do the math you don't read well enough
and very often those people were
brilliant
extraordinarily capable had real life
experience that demonstrated their
capacities and what they needed was an
environment that didn't judge them based
on a checklist
and actually assessed whether or not
they could think yeah i uh
the problem is one of high variance
the fact that evergreen did not turn
people away meant that there were people
there who just simply
weren't
you know the euphemism was college ready
right um
but the number of people who absolutely
were ready for the intellectual
environment but maybe didn't have the
background or all of the skills
necessary to slot well to be a good
student in a normal college where they
were anonymous to make a faculty and a
college's life easier right and so the
point was if you had faculty willing to
think carefully about why a particular
student was not succeeding and you had
students willing to try to figure out
you know how i can learn this in spite
of the fact that i'm not good at x or y
it was ideal yes but you know it carries
those two things together and separating
them would be uh
a good thing to do because a lot of
those students that are you know in many
cases our highest potential students are
not a good fit for our system yes and
therefore explicitly not a good fit for
elite institutions they are exactly who
get missed by so-called elite
institutions
okay one more
one more
uh
sentence from this piece we can do
better they say
scientists even as we are part of a
wonderful universal system for
generating knowledge are not necessarily
wiser or better than other human beings
can you imagine writing that sentence
and putting it into a published
[Music]
i don't know these guys i i don't want
to take them on personally but like
come on yeah that that sentence
that tells me right there that all this
talk about diversity equity inclusion is
an act that you that you don't know what
you're doing aren't necessary scientists
aren't necessarily better than other
human beings
what are you on about that's just that's
an insane
direction
is okay um so oh
go for it um i just wanted to add one
more thing we promised to come back to
this question of denaming buildings
renaming them recalibrating buildings
recalibrating the buildings um
the first of all i just want to oh you
know i think it is jonathan height who
did this first but his point was look
you got to choose
you can't have a social justice uh
oriented university and a truth seeking
university you have to pick between
those yes and this is this is the
um
the type specimen
of scientists pretending that you can do
both and the point is look the purpose
of science is truth-seeking
and here's where they've buried the
bodies
their point is well are you really going
to accept
that scientists don't have an obligation
to be decent people
no
the fact is scientists have the same
obligation as everyone else to be decent
people and it may exist in a somewhat
different context because of the
authority that is carried by having a
scientific degree but no we need to be
tolerant of the flaws of scientists we
need to recognize that people who have
absolutely vile pieces of their
character may also have transcendent
insight right i wish that wasn't the
case it would be cool if the best people
were always the most insightful people
but it's not true
isaac newton was a [ __ ] dick right
now we are not going to d isaac newton
the physics textbook because the man was
a jerk right likewise edison
likewise r.a fisher the father of
statistics right the father of
statistics was an evolutionary biologist
his work was absolutely transcendent now
he was also an anti-semite should i
not listen to his insights on biology
because he happened to be an anti-semite
that doesn't make any sense right the
fact is what i should do is i should say
here is a deeply flawed person who had
some insights about biology that were
truly important and well ahead of their
time and
i can live with those two things because
i'm an adult and there's nuance in my
mind right that is what we should be
doing now there is a question
there is a question about who you want a
statue of on your campus and who a
building should be named after i don't
think every time we find a flaw in
somebody
that we should go dename the building
right that doesn't make any sense but i
do think there are occasionally
especially given how much real work
needs to be done
right first of all there is real work
second of all you're
you're also doing something to people's
even the statues of people who we might
rather we wouldn't today build a statue
of right my feeling is you know what
uh cristobal cologne
goes by another name but are you gonna
tell people what it is christopher
columbus that's how you say it in
american um but cristobal cologne i
don't believe
is a figure that we should be especially
honoring especially as americans and
it's not that i don't think that there
was something about what he did that was
important and probably involved a whole
lot of personal strength
but the problem is
america
is not
downstream of christopher columbus right
we are a people that includes
indians right who suffered greatly as a
result of the personal strengths of
cristobal cologne and so my point is
celebrating him together as a people
doesn't really make sense but i don't
want to pretend he didn't exist either
yeah and i'm not
[Music]
i i guess the point is if there's a
statue of cristobal cologne i think it
should stay
would i argue to put one up no i
wouldn't right that's where we are but i
do want people and such such as the
nature of history
and you know we disappear our own
history at our peril
we disappear our own history at our
peril and frankly i want to be able to
stand in front of a statue that has a
mixed heritage indeed along with a
native american and say yeah i get i get
the problem of that guy right and you
get the importance of it and also i mean
just the nature of public art and by
which perhaps i'm including the names of
buildings if the you know on a on a
public university campus or even a
private university campus but uh you
know art that is available for people
who are freely walking and can stumble
upon it and say oh
oh well i wasn't expecting to see that
ah
i don't want to be thinking about this
right now i didn't know anything about
that well that's ugly
is it
is it a better human experience to be
guaranteed that you will never stumble
upon something that makes you feel ill
that makes you feel a little gross or a
lot gross or like
damn
genocide really here at this spot i
didn't know and it was that guy why are
we celebrating this guy well maybe the
public
the public representation of a person or
an event isn't inherently about
glorification right maybe it's about
representation and representation also
isn't inherently about celebration maybe
all of this is a way of of
educating us and making us more aware of
both of our history and of what we are
capable of in the future
and it shouldn't be
well you know whitewashed honestly is a
weird word to be using here but it
shouldn't be cleansed of all the things
that a person that who happens to be
alive and making decisions in 2022
decides is the thing that needs to
happen because
we don't only exist at this moment
and it is beyond foolish to imagine that
that's that that's the world we live in
enough of this recalibration culture
i want to say just just a little
vignette uh before we move on to the
next the next issue because this made me
think about something that i experienced
this week this this new herbert paper
and
it seems like in response to the krylov
paper from uh 13 months ago which we
talked about when it came out
and
you know this herbert paper begins as i
as i read with the the idea
that those of us who are resisting such
measures are are interested in
maintaining an alienating or hostile
workplace
which is absurd it's just absurd on its
face
but i actually
i think it's not just absurd but i think
it's quite the opposite
i think that what you dei people are
doing is creating a
a alienating and hostile workplace and
in fact ecosystem for all of the rest of
us everyone who resists
and uh i have a not workplace story
because my workplace is here and you are
not creating an alienating or hostile
workplace for me thank you for which i
appreciate uh you and the fact that
you're not i can't recover grammatically
from that um construction but i
appreciate you trying to finish this
sentence yeah no thank you period
um
but i had an experience this week uh
that
struck me as
clearly
downstream of one of the sets of of
initiatives that the dei people would
would have us embrace
i went to a market
um you're not writing something for me
no that's a note to remember sorry i
went to a local market
that uh
that
has a parking lot such that there's
really only one way in and you have to
there's basically one parking space that
is the most prominent in the parking lot
and there was a big guy sitting in that
most prominent space
in a minivan with the driver's door
propped open and he kind of had one of
his legs hang out at the door a really
big guy you know very masculine seeming
um seemed very strong kind of time worn
embattled and bittered
i don't know the guy
i know that i
walked out of my way not to walk past
him
which is the natural way to get into
that market anyone who's ever been at
this market will will know that the way
you would normally go into the market
through that parking lot is right past
his open door where he had his
leg out
and i noticed um both on my way in on my
way out it was a beautiful day and there
were a lot of people around
that i was not the only one that no one
was walking right right by him which
they normally would have done
and um
the thing is he wasn't just a big
potentially threatening dude
who was doing something kind of display
like with his door open his leg out um
but he was also wearing fishnet
stockings
and i think a mini skirt
and garish makeup
on his face
and
that didn't make him a woman
but what it did do
i suspect was made a lot of people
more confused about their own responses
if that had just been
a guy dressed like a guy that guy
dressed like that guy doing that thing
it would have been read as what it was
which was
a subtle
threat
to
really everyone but certainly women
and because he was dressed in sort of
feminine tropes
nothing happened
now would anything have happened would
it would would an employee from the
store have come out and told him that he
needed to close his door and go
somewhere else if he had just been
dressed as a guy i don't know maybe not
but i think the chances that this would
happen with him just the way he was
are much much lower
and this is downstream of diversity
equity and inclusion stuff
because until yesterday everyone knew
what a woman was and that putting on a
skirt doesn't make you a woman
and as we've said over and over and over
again this does not deny actually truly
trans people
but this man
no
this man was doing something aggressive
and threatening in a public place in a
way that made it less likely that anyone
would call him out on it
um
all right
this only works at the rule of thumb
level
but
all of the trans people that i have
known
well enough to really say that i know
them as people
to a person
have made every effort
to fit in to their chosen gender as
seamlessly as possible right
what you're describing is somebody who
has weaponized their
chosen gender and raises questions about
why they chose it in other words it's
the point that you get a weapon for
doing this is the point that you get to
be
a burly guy who people steer clear of
but now you get to make them feel
uncomfortable about it because you know
is it transphobia that's causing them to
do that
all right so i guess the question is
every time i see somebody
for whom their presentation
is aggressive and which the point is not
to minimize
the
sense of
uh discourseness or just coarseness no
discordantness would be the word i was
looking for
um
you know anytime somebody is
um
aggressively
utilizing those tropes so that they are
in conflict with
how they present
such that they would know that that's
what they're doing it raises a question
about why they're doing it yeah
yes no that that's exactly right
uh so just
one more
note about this um
i've been reading of late some uh
historical fiction about uh world war ii
and pre-world war ii era
i think i made i mentioned a number of
weeks back about
a novel about hedy lamarr
and i've also been reading some fiction
written during the gilded age and
and
all of these books have strong female
characters what
when you say hedy lamarr it is almost
impossible not to quote harvey corman
say headley
in uh blazing sounds blazing yes yes
um
yeah not not that lamar the the real but
he he spent that whole movie correcting
people because of that exact
problem but exactly
um
so so books ranging from 1880s through
1940s uh written either about that era
or during that area with
strong female characters which reveal of
course that there have been strong women
who have been you know fighting against
the particular strictures of the
cultural expectations of them because of
the sex they were born to for you know
for a long time
and
i was reminded with this
with running into this guy in this
parking lot
of
this flyer of a 1914 feminist rally that
a few years back barry weiss actually
posted and if you can show my screen
here this is from 1914
what is feminism come and find out first
feminist mass meeting
with the at the people's institute at
cooper union 1914
and
the topics uh the subject is supposedly
breaking into the human race and the
topics given by a series of speakers are
the right to work
the right of the mother to her
profession
the right to her convictions the right
to her name the right to organize the
right to ignore fashion i love that one
and the right to specialize in home
industries i don't know what that last
one means
but all the rest of them i think are
extraordinary yeah um and i'm i could
probably figure it out i welcome someone
telling me what the right to specialize
in home industries means
because it seems like that is the thing
that women have always
been in fact you know canalized into
right now that does that
specialize within home industries yeah
yeah
anyway but the rest of them you know the
right to her own name to her convictions
to organize to ignore fashion to work
and um the right of the mother to her
profession not just to work but to work
even after you've become a mother
uh these are this this is feminism in
1914 this is what women were fighting
for and in response to
barry back in early 2018's this is
several years old at this point
why is my computer not coming up
i said okay so in feminism 1914 we had
the right to work to have convictions to
keep one's name to organize and to
ignore fashion feminism in 2018 and this
holds today
unfortunately the right to ignore
science to attain power through
victimhood and to make arguments that
nobody is allowed to dispute
so this was sort of just as um let's see
early 2018 maybe this was before
actually me too really came no me too
what happened me too was this was me too
was full swing and me too was a movement
that we needed and it was not the
movement that we needed right like me
too
needed to say some things to the world
we needed a me too movement not the one
we got yeah exactly
and so
in the in sort of the thick of that
there was a you know hashtag believe all
women moment
as if women like all the other human
beings out there that say the other 50
can't and wouldn't lie for you know
for personal profit under some
circumstances not all
but also um
not none right and so
that
you know
what feminism has become is
terrible
it's tragic uh but it's also just become
even more ridiculous by the idea now
that well okay well if women get that
right
and you're a dude and you don't have
anything else to recommend to the
progressive stack well then all you have
to do is put on fishnets and now um you
got to believe me not only that i'm a
woman but anything else i want to claim
so you know this
that's what that's part of what and it's
not entirely on your doorstep dei guys
but the diversity equity and inclusion
community has brought us that
that's
nightmare which is effectively a hostile
and alienating space it's not just a
workspace it's an everything space
hostile and alienating to everyone who
is interested in
being good and doing good for each other
so i want to
definitely resonate with your point
about hostile work environment and
and larger environment but i also want
to point out
it's not just that uh
the ei creates a hostile work
environment
that is its mechanism of action that's
its mo
right it's modus operandi yes and the
point is that's how it gains power is by
creating an environment in which you are
unsafe and in which what happens is
at the point that the mob focuses on you
you are now in danger not only of being
accused of terrible things but losing
your right to earn losing your ability
to advance right so the point is what
you want to avoid is the anger of the
mob which causes you to become their
tool or to be cast out yes and so
uh it reminds me a little bit
there was an i think it was the delilah
affair at the beginning of the george w
bush administration there was this one
democrat who had been brought in
and i forgot what he did but something
in the white house
and
he wrote an article at some point he was
very alarmed
that
there was no policy arm
of the administration it was all pr
going on in the in the white house
yeah it was all spin and there was there
were no discussions about what we should
be doing as a nation to solve x y and z
problem all it was was basically how do
we accomplish these goals that we walked
through the door with right
and it alarmed him in any way he wrote
about it and terrible things happened of
course because you're not allowed to say
those kinds of things but somewhere in
that affair i believe that's where this
comes from um the point was
not only are these people abusing power
it's who they are
that's what this is this this
administration is about the abuse of
power i would say the same thing about
the biden administration incidentally
but
the fact is
creation a claiming that we have a
hostile work environment and we need to
render it on hostile as you are making
that environment hostile and really the
point is oh
you want to make it hostile and you want
to be immunized from anybody pointing
out that that's what you're doing
and so the whole point is what we're
trying to do is create a non-hostile
environment no
quite the opposite preemptively claim
that your goals are the opposite of what
they are or the are the opposite of what
you are actually going to do perhaps
it's just collateral damage even if you
know maybe you just don't even care that
it's hostile now
uh and i guess the one the one final
thing i would say here before we move on
is
we were getting there
right and you know this again is a point
that we've made a lot but the 20th
century saw tremendous advances
women's rights civil rights gay rights
workers rights children's rights you
know all of these demographics and all
of these
real
pressing
human rights issues
that
really
the liberals won yep we did it well we
weren't we did it we made the world
better we weren't there and in fact
there are a lot of conservatives out
there
vast majority of them who adopted those
values as part of their own and are now
the defenders of them because what we
have now is people who call themselves
on the left
destroying it you know undoing undoing
the game so many people now uh would
never say yeah i'm a feminist
or would question whether or not we need
movements to maintain uh the hard-won
civil rights that happened you know
through have happened throughout history
but you know came to a came to a four in
the 1960s
and these are not these are not by and
large bad people or mean-spirited people
they're just fed up with the lies that
they're being told about about what is
actually happening so you know stop
undoing history stop pretending that we
haven't already gotten a tremendous
amount of the way that we need to go and
you know
if you're a scientist
consider doing science consider actually
when you're trying to figure out if
something is true like for instance uh
there are you know not not enough
however you define that uh black faculty
among the science sciences among
scientists
what are your possible explanations for
why and you need to come up with all of
them you can't come up with one and
stick with that one and claim that
you're doing science because you're not
yep absolutely
we need we need science back in science
yeah
yeah
all right
segway not totally obvious um we'll find
a way to connect it yeah uh
healing and illness and pathogens and
yeah points i want to
i don't think we should smoke on there
oh that's not the kind of joint you
might just
would i know where to put my hands on a
joint but um anyway
that was an odd digression um all right
i'm you man yeah i blame me also
who else would we blame the dog isn't
even here no it's not like that you know
that
they don't know that something like that
it's not like that the dog knows it's
not like that you're about to talk about
your joints yes i am about to talk about
my choice all right so i need to tell a
little story here um this all goes under
the heading of laboratory of the self
which is a term that we use in our book
and i will defend here before i tell you
what i think i've discovered
so
um i was sick about a week ago i had a
little cold that i picked up from one of
our kids
and it was annoying
and then it seemed to
go away all right seemed to be breaking
up i was coughing but i was coughing up
stuff it was productive i tested
negative for kobe twice i
certainly wasn't coveted
and yesterday
things took a turn for the worse
um we happened to be out of the house we
went to lunch i felt okay at lunch
and then after lunch
um
my cough picked up like crazy i
definitely
felt sick um
and
uh
anyway it was it got progressively worse
through the day and through yesterday
evening
um
so
i raised this because a couple of
phenomena went along with this a you
know i just sort of had the sense of
there's a metaphor i like circling the
drain right i like circling the drain as
a metaphor because you can circle the
drain at a great distance and you're a
long way from going down the drain but
there's a point at which you just feel
that force a little bit and you're like
well you know under ordinary
circumstances it's kind of hard to
imagine how you end up dead but from
here i can see how it could happen right
um
so you didn't tell me yesterday that you
felt like you might be circling the
drain i was circling the drain at a
great distance i was nice man
you might mention these things to your
wife
[Laughter]
now you can hear me coughing yeah um
anyway
no uh this is i mean i knew you weren't
doing well i wasn't well and i wasn't
worried you asked me if i was worried i
wasn't worried i just had the sense of
like oh yeah
ask you if you're worried i said i'm
worried you're like i'm not like well
okay
in any case um
it was bad but a couple of things
happened yesterday also one
my so you those who are long term
or even short term watchers in the
podcast will know that i fell off my
bike a couple weeks ago and was uh
injured in a number of ways
the injuries have progressed a little
bit so i
believe i know through
seeing our our wonderful doctor dr
miller
that i fractured my sacrum
so right above the tailbone
and i've been sort of hobbling around
it's been getting better fits and starts
if i push things too much it gets a
little worse if i take it easy it gets a
bit better it's been getting better
though over the course of this time but
the pain has moved around okay it's
moved into my right
hip
socket and i think that's because
whatever the sacrum injury is is causing
me to walk a little
asymmetrically and so anyway it's
putting strain on whatever other damage
i did when i fell and anyway it's been
it's been a slower process healing than
i would have liked
but it's been getting progressively
better over the last couple of weeks and
yesterday it started getting
way worse
and i thought first of all i should tell
you dr miller told me a ghost story
neither of us thought that this was
likely to be the case but he said look
i think you're going to get better but
there is one bad outcome that we can't
rule out here and the bad outcome is if
you do if you fracture the head of your
femur
that basically the head of your femur
could die from lack of circulation and
then you'd need a hip replacement
neither of us thought it was likely
enough for me to get an x-ray but it was
a ghost story he told me that has not
apparently gone away
so
when my pain flared up yesterday in my
hip it was like oh geez
why am i getting worse
and i didn't initially put it together
but it came with one other factor
i had this wound on my hand
right from when i fell and you know i'm
in my 50s
the first thing you notice as you get
older is wound healing gets way slower
and you'll even notice that in your 30s
right it's like really conspicuous how
slow wound healing goes
um and this one has been getting better
and it's annoying that two weeks out i
still you know have this wound but it's
been getting better every day and i've
been paying attention to that and
yesterday it started getting way worse
now visibly there was no change but the
pain associated with it was just
you know like 10 times what it had been
in the last week
and that caused me to think and this is
where we get to the laboratory of the
self that all of this fits together so i
should say just let me complete the
pathogen part of the story last night
or yesterday evening i went to bed at i
don't know
seven eight o'clock at night
um and i didn't get back up until this
morning but in the middle of the night i
clearly had a fever and then it broke
and i feel loads better today in fact i
feel pretty well other than the fact
that i have this
cough which i think is just the final
stages of the
the illness
but
here's what i realized
the
pattern of pain in my hip and my hand
suggests that one of the mechanisms of
illness involves
a threshold of sensitivity to pain
right now
the counterintuitive part of this
evolutionarily speaking
is
we have sensory neurons all over our
bodies for obvious reasons they send
information that's important in order to
keep you functional right if you do a
little damage to some soft tissue maybe
you need some pain in order to get you
to not use that tissue in order to give
it time to heal this sort of thing but
even even at subconscious levels right
like you're constantly
navigating and adjusting in ways that
you don't even know you're adjusting
because your your body is sending you
signals that allow you to you know ease
up on something so that some healing
that is from some injury you don't even
know existed uh can can progress totally
and in fact we could say that some
fraction
maybe it's even all but at least some
large fraction of what we call
discomfort are these little sub uh
liminal messages that tell us you know
take it easy on that elbow or you know
you've been leaning too hard on that
side for too many hours or whatever
so mostly
our
bodies have a ton of data flooding
towards our brain at all times and
almost all of it is thrown out almost
all of the time because it's not useful
to you right so the point is there's a
huge amount of potential information you
could tune into most of it never gets to
the part of you that takes action or
changes anything and some of it gets to
not quite conscious but enough to get
you to shift in your chair or whatever
but the fact that both my hip and my
hand went in the wrong direction
yesterday i know nothing about my hand
was any worse it just felt way worse
tells you what's going on here in all
probabilities so this is a hypothesis
obviously but what's going on is that
there's a threshold of pain
that can be adjusted in the context of
illness which raises a question about
the kinds of joint aches that go along
with something like the flu right are
those joint aches
the result of the fact that those
tissues are in some way affected by the
illness or is it the result of some
other mechanism that is causing pains
that you are ordinarily completely
incapable of detecting to suddenly be
above threshold where you pay attention
and i'm going to make an argument that
there are a couple reasons you might
have such a system
but
what happened when i got better last
night when my fever broke my hip feels
fine today in fact it feels better than
it's felt by a fair amount than it did
three days ago well you were super easy
on it for a solid that's certainly true
but it is also true that the threshold
my hand also feels just fine
so and interestingly none of my other
joints hurt so what i think happened
was the threshold
not exactly but we can we can get there
but
what i think happened was this illness
whatever it was caused a threshold
adjustment in my sensitivity it did not
go as far as a flu does where all of
your joints ache i didn't tune into any
of my joints other than the one that was
above normal in terms of you know pain
and the indicator that this was just the
pain threshold issue is my hand which
i'm certain was as good yesterday as it
is today but felt loads worse yeah and
it's i mean it's fabulous at one level
that you have
those two very distinct
uh types of injuries from the same event
uh that you you had
input in the same direction yesterday
with regard to your hip you have no
independent way you know unless unless
right you have no way of knowing if the
healing is getting better or worse or
slowed or anything um but when you're
talking about a wound a wound on the
skin a flesh i can see it you can see it
yeah i can see it and
the
the i'm not doing the story justice
really but the way in which the degree
to which the part of me felt bad was in
lock step between these two things right
as my hip started to drive me crazy
yesterday my hands started to drive me
crazy yeah now and that i mean
her experience so you know the boys and
you and i and our dog all went down to
the river and uh
i think it was hard for all the the
other four of us including the dog
although she said less about it um
at any moment i was like well wait a
minute
what is it that you feel you're clearly
not doing well but you know is it is it
your hip or is it the cold like which is
it and it was just like it was
everything all at once so it all it all
sort of
congealed into a single
pain event uh which was very interesting
because they have completely different
ideologies yeah so this actually brings
me to the question of so the hypothesis
is that there's this threshold and it's
a general pain sensitivity threshold
that usually hides everything from us
that's one part of the hypothesis the
other question is is that an adaptation
or is that a failure does illness
disrupt the system my instinct here is
that it doesn't that this is an
adaptation and the question is why why
would you have such a threshold
and i've come up with so
by analogy i want to use
a camera so
first of all let's just let's talk for a
second about fever because fever is a
very interesting phenomena right
remember the last fever you had when you
were when you were really sick right
you feel
very cold you've got the chills right
you get under the covers right because
you your sensations are very cold and
then somebody puts their hand in your
foot oh you're burning up you are hot
but you feel cold
now the reason for that is very
straightforward
there's a reason to have a fever an
adaptive reason we talk about it in our
book people now understand
that fever is a way of taking a pathogen
that is adapted to a particular
temperature i.e human temperature and
throwing at a curveball hey now it's
going to get super hot right
so that's a good way of fighting a
pathogen
but how does it get accomplished
well it's as if you've got
some sort of a formula that keeps your
temperature really close to 98.6
fahrenheit because your enzymes and
everything else about you requires it's
very narrow tolerances right a couple
degrees off really throws a curveball at
your whole system
so
if you're going to
um
generate a fever in order to defeat a
pathogen it's like you take whatever the
various
uh it's not it's not going to function
in the in the way a formula does but
there's something that's akin to a
formula in your system that keeps that
temperature in the same place and it
adjusts how much you're radiating how
much uh fuel you're burning
so that you know you end up at that
target place
well imagine that in the condition that
your body detects that you're sick with
something for which a fever would be
useful
it subtracts two degrees from the final
output of the equation
so that instead of being 98.6
you're two degrees up right you now have
a fever but what would that feel like it
would feel like
i'm two degrees colder than i would like
to be right and so it cost relative to
the ambient environment which didn't
change relative to the ambient
environment which then of course makes
the fever cheaper you diving under the
covers right an insulative layer means
that the amount of fuel that has to be
burned in order to generate that is much
lower than if you were out in the wind
right
so anyway it's that
you know subtract two or subtract three
from the final output of all of the
detectors that tell you how hot you are
and therefore whether you need to
radiate more or generate more heat right
is rather like the adjustment i don't
know if you can see that on a camera a
good one there's an adjustment for
the sensitivity of the light meter
to light
so
in the case that you have a subject that
will confuse the light meter like a
backlit subject right where the back the
subject will end up very very dark you
say well i want you to overexpose by a
stock that means double the amount of
light hitting the sensor before you tell
me i've got enough
um so is it long
stop is a double one full stop is a
double oh it's a doubling of incident
light yep
um so that kind of calibration or
recalibration in light of a corrective
factor can then fix the photo
and what i'm arguing
is that this pain threshold thing is
likely to
function in the same way and that my
weird set of injuries overlapping this
pathology reveals that thing now why
would the pain threshold you know so
then this implies that something like a
flu in which your joints ache
right maybe even the headaches or
whatever that comes along with such
things might just be that you're tuning
into a bunch of data that's ordinarily
invisible to you right and that that you
know maybe that's what a headache is
right maybe it's the buzz of data coming
off of your your brain and uh you're
tuning into it or maybe not
but um anyway why
all right two hypotheses
one of the hypotheses
is that and i think we know this to be
true there are certain kinds of healing
that can only happen while you're
dormant i don't know if you have to
actually be asleep but there's certain
kinds of processes that you actually
can't be you know out and about
and so
my experience when we were out yesterday
before i was able to come home and go to
sleep
was
you know i just wanted to sit somewhere
i didn't really want to interact i just
wanted to find a place you know and just
sort of sit and for you guys to do your
thing and you guys of course were like a
little concerned about me and
didn't want to leave me alone but the
point was the
pain threshold thing
might serve to get you
to not push any limits to seek out a
place where you could just sort of stop
moving that those things
might be key to healing yep
the other thing
the other possible explanation
would be
this requires you to think in terms of
lineage for it to make sense
but in the context of a pathogen
an individual's interests
involve not just getting better but not
giving the pathogen to those with whom
they have aligned interests or shared
teens
right
so not getting you to pass on your
illness
is key and so another thing another
effect
of feeling uncomfortable and in pain and
all of those things might be to get you
to just kind of not hang out with people
and you know this would
also potentially a value of feeling a
bit grumpy about it and
all the things that come along with it
so anyway making people not want to hang
out with you either because yeah oh
that's good yes becoming intolerable
could could save them uh catching the
path anyway so
these hypotheses are not all equal
strength i'm
i'm uh
i'm not sure i heard clearly the
distinct hypotheses here so the first
hypothesis is the
pain threshold adjustment issue
assuming that's adaptive and not a
failure right assuming it's a feature
and not a bug
one thing is it could be that that
increasing your sensitivity to your
joints then causing you to feel painful
all over
could cause you to stop being active
which could be key to healing right the
dormancy could be the value or it could
be
breaking your usual social patterns to
protect others who
it would be better if they didn't get
sick
so that's two right no three
pain threshold okay uh adjustment is an
adaptation
why would it be an adaptation a it could
be about increasing speed of healing b
it could be about not passing on the
disease
well it's two alternative hypotheses
predicated on a first one yeah so there
there's an alternative to the the second
unnamed one to the first level is it's
not an adaptation it's it's just an
effect uh it's you know it's it's noise
um so you know you test that one first
say okay if if if so um if adaptation
then adaptation for what and then you've
got two downstream of that right and so
i mean to complete it we've got uh
predictions
for
all of these
um so first of all let me defend
laboratory of the cell for a second
people
um you've got a problem which is
yourself
is a difficult environment to do science
on
because you're not objective about it
right you're a big anecdote
well you are a big anecdote
um or maybe the pants just make you look
like a big anecdote but nonetheless
you're a big anecdote itself a
hypothesis worthy of being tested worthy
of being tested although
yes no don't be tested um but anyway
uh
here's the thing you are a big anecdote
that's a problem on the other
hand you have more information
about yourself
than you do the next nearest person
by a huge degree right i know you better
than anyone else on earth knows you
um but the degree to which
things about you are mysterious to me
and that i don't i don't even know their
questions because they happen internal
to your mind and you you don't tell me
enough that i would detect them
you know i know much less about what
it's like to be you than to be me
obviously right so that means that the
degree to which being an anecdote is bad
is in some sense um offset offset by the
degree to which you have way better data
on yourself than anyone else and so
paying attention to these patterns
internally is a great way of discovering
the way certain things work and a number
of places where i found stuff out that
actually allowed me to make my life
materially better by noticing a pattern
is large
but
it generates hypotheses
you then need to figure out how to test
them and so one question would be do
others see
a relationship between injury
and illness that reveals the same
threshold adjustment
right and the pattern is you know
complex enough that it should be
conspicuous if it's visible in other
words i got to the place that my
injuries showed up as pains but my
regular my other joints that were not
injured did not that's an interesting
pattern
the question about whether or not
it is a matter
of
protecting others from a pathogen
suggests and this is a tougher one to
test but it's at least a prediction of
proof of concept that you could have
such a prediction would be that species
in which
sociality brings individuals together
would show this threshold effect
much more precipitously than species
that were not generally social good yes
um
and then the one about healing this is a
weaker test because there are other
things that might point in the same
direction
but
you that the
triggering of this threshold mechanism
would result in
an
increased rate of healing
uh
for those who were in a position to
respond to it and those who were not
right in other words if you had to go to
work anyway and so you were still active
did it
increase the amount of time that the
pathogen took to
uh to go away
um
something like that i had
one more thing but i can't remember what
it was
well
um
we've been out for a while
you also want to talk about land sharks
well of course do you still want to talk
about land sharks you can save land
sharks for next week let's let's do it
quickly okay um all right so what i'm
going to do is show you a little video
that emerged apparently as a part of
shark week now i am not a member of the
religion that celebrates shark week what
is shark i think it's a discovery
channel thing where they spend a whole
week on sharks oh it's actual sharks
it's not like uh financial advisors or
loan charts no no no no no no that's
spelled differently
no it's not enough it's not is it
no
no shark week okay do they have ray week
they have skate week
uh
no i think there's a roller derby week
but that's obviously much narrower sure
yeah yeah yeah so elasmobrands we're
going to celebrate them but only the
sharks only the show yeah we're going to
celebrate the sharks and we're just
going to some dangers pretend
awkwardly at times the rays in the
skates don't exist yeah exactly exactly
not the choice i would have made uh
right me either but you know okay so
sure why we don't have a gigantic nature
channel
i i guess that is the reason yeah so
shark week is uh celebrating all things
shark i don't really know i've never
seen it but i i understand from the
channels i pay attention to that that
this piece of video emerged on shark
weekend caused a certain amount of uh
okay so i have not seen the video in
question you're only gonna have this
now we have here
is a
shark
that's oh that is a shark yeah and he's
maneuvering around using his pectoral
fins and at one point here he actually
kind of goes over
a little barrier
uh no that is not a shark um but anyway
we're about to because we've got very
shallow uh presumably salt water here
like an inner tidal zone almost maybe
yeah um with a shark
right little little leopard spotted
shower cute little guy um using his
bread set as pictorial fins to
um gosh propel himself over very
in very very shallow water now can we
agree and or his i mean his gills are
still underwater right yeah well they're
moist i think the gills go out of water
here briefly yeah and then he maneuvers
into the next little pool now the claim
here is that this is the first time this
has been seen who said that you see the
discovery channel shark week today
shark week yeah uh it the first time
it's been seen yeah not by the sharks
presumably
ah well that's the question this is like
cristobal cologne discovering america
right that's the first time sharks have
done this no
so
right
snowball cologne who discovered a pair
of continents with something like 50
million people living very well there
the sharks
have presumably been trying this out
this is
about the time i discovered manhattan
how much did you pay for it
too much and i didn't even get to keep
it but yeah um
yeah i mean
is it possible that uh some
videographer witnessed the very first
time that is shark now i mean it's
possible but apparently but even the
claim that this is the first time it's
been observed i find very unlikely for
reasons i want to briefly explore okay
so observed by people is the idea yeah
okay um so
uh
in evolutionary biology we sometimes use
the metaphor of the adaptive landscape
in which opportunities are pictured as
peaks and obstacles of moving from one
opportunity to the next are valleys
now the reason that this is useful
as a metaphor is that it highlights
certain counter-intuitive things about
what actually uh drives and impedes
evolution
or adaptive evolution at least
which is to say
the depth of a valley
dictates the likelihood of a creature
evolving from one opportunity to a
better opportunity not the difference in
height between the two opportunities
there can be some very good way of being
that's pretty near where you are but if
the obstacle and the evolutionary
obstacle to getting there is
particularly deep
particularly deep
you're unlikely to jump that gap
now the opposite is also true we don't
talk about this as much
but opportunities where there is no gap
where what there is the gentle slope
where if you evolve in this direction
things just simply start getting better
and keep getting better for some
long period those are almost certain to
be crossed
and so
my point would be
this exact adaptation is known from i've
got at least four examples in mind
different clades that have done it
all right we've got coelacanths we got
lungfish we got mud skippers
and now i've forgotten mine
coelacanths and lungfish could
plausibly be the same uh the same event
given that they are sort of they're both
near the base of the um
the sarcopterygian tree uh and we
tetrapods uh are the other big group and
since we're out of water who knows you
know it's possible that sort of at the
base of the sarcopte the lopefin fish
tree
uh you had this ability and both
lungfish and coelacanths inherited that
ability from their most recent common
ancestor possible i think and it's been
many years since i looked at it but i
think it's more likely to be a
parallelism where those two clades both
had the characteristics that made this
likely to evolve yeah and it's been a
while since i've taught vertebrate
evolution so i haven't looked but as i
remember it these sort of you know
coelacanths lungfish
tetrapods group
the resolution between those three
clades isn't
uh isn't totally clear i don't think we
know for sure who's most basal within
that group
it's a scaly question at the very least
yeah sorry but
anyway
the point is so wait you had uh mud
skippers seal counts lungfish you have
another one i've forgotten what it is i
had one okay so mudskippers being
actinops act ray-finned fish
uh you know solidly would then basically
name a fish it's probably an
ecnopterygian okay sharks sharks aren't
telecats aren't lung fish aren't um but
almost every sturgeon
sturgeon are acting outdoor jeans but
not teleos anyway it doesn't matter it
doesn't matter but point is look
there are lots of circumstances in which
something that we would call a fish fish
by common parlance
faces a situation in which either
it's trapped with a danger that it could
survive if it can get out of the
body of water that has the danger and
into a body of water that doesn't or
more often there's some opportunity
there's a puddle that contains prey over
there but i'm over here and there's a
little bit of somewhat dry land between
here and there and if i could only just
you know wiggle my way across that piece
of land there are lots and lots of
circumstances in which it's useful to be
able to do a little bit of locomotion on
land and they happen to be armed
with pectoral fins
terrible
not pretty good actually but
but anyway lots of circumstances in
which it would be useful to be able to
do that the mode of locomotion actually
leads directly to this discovery in
other words the wiggling
motion of a fish in swimming also puts
the pectoral fins you know alternately
on the substrate and so
my point is
this is one of these things that is
probably unknown because we haven't
looked for it not because it's uncommon
yes and this is there's another one of
these they're not just going to lay
there and die they're going to do
everything they can to get out of a
situation if suddenly they find
themselves in shallow water right it's
bound to that lateral undulation and
they've got pictorial fins and you know
put them together and do what you can
right and the number of individuals who
were birthed to some creature who
succeeded at this and therefore didn't
starve is liable to be large and so the
question really is a
how common is this behavior in clades
where we haven't seen it my guess is
it's a lot more common than we think
yeah um
b any kind of like you know fish um
probably not like a deep body form fish
but you know any kind of fish that tends
to be in intertidal zones you know with
tide pools that sometimes will dry up
more than they were expecting
yeah tide pools that dry up or tide
pools where an unusual tide will make a
puddle wet and an animal will get
trapped and it has to get out because
that pool isn't going to be wet again
for another month or something yeah and
just so deep body form just refers to
sort of a
like an angel fish imagine an angel fish
or a sun fish one of these fish that's
basically like a disk on the side where
you know no matter how hard they try
they try to use their pic well a their
pectoral fins tend to be
tend to be up on the body so they
probably wouldn't even reach but they'd
also just tip over yeah so you need to
have a somewhat flattened form for this
for this to work yep
um but anyway the number of
circumstances is huge it's not likely to
happen for anything in deep bodies of
water
but there are a lot of animals that have
a niche that puts them in proximity with
idiosyncratic shorelines this is not the
other bound to be bound to be somewhat
common and
also highly likely this is one of these
questions where
if you were to survey the indigenous
people of all of the coastlines of the
world my guess is you'd come up with a
bunch of them that had seen this
behavior of course sharks do that right
of course sharks do that yeah and that
this is new to science which i don't
even know if it is new to science but if
it's new to science it's really cool if
it's not new to science it's still
really cool well i mean one of the
things you're saying maybe the least
interesting one but you know
if it's new if it's not you to science
discovery channel will hear about it
if it's not new to humanity
but it is new to science uh the claim
stands right right um and you know this
this is the kind of thing that the the
dei folks claim to be caring about right
like don't don't imagine that you with
your wonderful
wizarding scientific ways can come in
and and see things that actually other
people have been observing for a while
and claim it as your own
um well okay let's let's imagine that if
you know given given what this
particular thing is
it almost certainly has been seen by
other human beings but that doesn't mean
that those other human beings inherently
uh had the
you know the the
i used the term wizarding but you know
the the scientific abilities to consider
what it means or under what
circumstances it would evolve or when it
might happen
when it might happen they might have the
skills to have deduced that if it had
practical application for them you know
if
if the sharks are good eating and there
is a way to uh predict when they might
go kind of pseudo-terrestrial and thus
get them to go into something where
they'll be easier to catch well you can
be pretty sure that where those sharks
exist there are going to be people who
have a good sense of how it is that they
locomotive or land when they do yep
and i must tell you in this case um
had we been somewhere in the field and
observed this
i would definitely have thought it was
hugely cool and i would remember it for
the rest of my life and i would have uh
certainly discussed it
i don't know that i would have even
thought that what i was looking at was
new to science and therefore
needed a report and you know there is a
mechanism it gets done i think less
these days but
um
there used to be natural history notes
where important features of behavior
that had never been observed before and
never been recorded in scientific
literature before could be reported
without you needing to have a you know
data justification because i saw this
animal do that thing which says no i
published one of these about about my
frogs
it's like some little piece of you know
observed predation right uh attempted
predation on these poison frogs in
madagascar where like okay enough people
enough people are just interested but
also enough people are thinking about
both the boas and the zonosaurus which
of these lizards and these frogs and the
toxins and the fogs there's a lot of
ways in that you might really want to
know if anyone has ever observed either
successful or attempted predation on
these frogs and you know i happen to see
two and i don't know the fate of the
zonosaur and i do know the fate of the
boa which is that
the boa took this frog into its mouth
gently chewed on it for 10 minutes um
finally released the frog frog went on
to be fine went on to become a mother
who who fed her kids and the boa um
moved dens shortly thereafter and i
think was fine although i'm not actually
totally sure because i didn't see it
after a couple weeks um but anyway
natural history notes where there's no
there's no
experiment of hypothesis or experiment
or you know rigorous data collection
it's hey i was in the field and i saw
this
and this might this is interesting maybe
it's just interesting but it might also
be useful to other people well i mean
i think there is a way
in which it fits exactly the um
falsificationist ethos of science
in the following sense
anything that you have seen happen once
happens absolutely and so if we assume
that the hypothesis is that that
behavior does not exist until evidence
accumulates that it does how much
evidence do you need one honest report
of having seen it is enough to say that
it is at least within the realm of
things that happen that's exactly right
and also there's always a problem for
animal behaviorists
uh in that in order to do careful
rigorous work uh we need to you know
spend hundreds thousands of hours in the
field taking careful notes by you know
whatever means that we have established
in advance
um but the really coolest stuff may
still be out of our view you know the
more socially complex the organisms are
that we're watching the more likely
they're gonna hide from us and not you
know do the the interesting stuff where
we can see it and it's just also just
very likely to be rare and so one event
uh you cannot run statistics on but it
still does is worthy of discussion and
of publication and of um figuring out
what else must be true if you know if if
that thing happens if for instance
the
you know what she called i think aptly
war
that jane goodall observed between the
two troops of uh chimps at gambi which
you know there's objection to the term
but
uh never again did she see anything
exactly like that and thank god that she
didn't was like well i can't report that
because i just saw it once like no you
report when the chimps engage in war
you've totally reported that that's a
great example
um yeah i would point out actually
there's one of these
for me where i have not published a note
but probably should have
um when i was working on tent making
bats
there was a uh a survey article that
compiled a review article that compiled
all of the information on tent making
bats and it you know had useful tables
in it where it took all of the species
or 16 species that are known to engage
in the behavior and described what sorts
of plants they used and the
architectures and all
but the problem is
i became quickly convinced
that the
species
that was most commonly observed to be a
tent maker never makes tense at all that
it's a tent thief is this aj yeah
artibius jimmy census and the thing that
first clued me into that was it was the
only one that used all of the
architectures that were known from that
location
right but so you have to understand
nobody had seen a bat make a tent so the
inference that they made you were the
first person ever to either see yeah
well and in this case you
so i mean how are we not in a little bit
of the same situation do you are you
certain
how certain are you
that no native peoples had ever observed
a bat naked tent pretty sure
well it's a lot more subtle and cryptic
here here's the reason for a number of
reasons then here's the reason i think
going over land yeah yeah but there's
also a technical reason okay um
bats are very shy about uh making tents
so they kind of don't do it when you're
standing there yeah
um
they
do it under cover of darkness yeah and
enter a cover of the leaves that they
are modifying to make into the tents
right so the point is these are
happening low in the understory of a
forest that absorbs 99 of the light that
hits it before it gets the floor so the
dark floor in the night
and they are very sensitive about people
so what i was able to do to observe this
was i knew enough about the tense and
the behavior to spot one that had just
begun
and i set up infrared this was before
infrared cameras were i mean the cameras
were available but there wasn't night
shot on
video cameras that you could buy so i
made an illuminator out of leds from uh
from basically uh remote controls for
tvs
i built them into a lucite block that
right 150. no it was the bat bright 4
000. i i i knew 150 was low i i kept
making ones that didn't have enough
power and i kept increasing the power
the batbright 4000 is the one that
really revolutionized the industry
me being the industry um but anyway i i
built this thing and it was powered off
at 12 volt batteries which i hauled into
the forest and hauled out during the day
and charged them and i set up these uh
infrared cameras basically just bank
surveillance cameras which are sensitive
in the infrared and i was able to put
that under the leaf that was being
modified and i could sit you know 50
meters away where i wasn't disturbing
the animal and just quietly sit there
and watch the thing happen so the point
is the conditions
would it a
if i hadn't had the tech i wouldn't have
been able to see anything
if i stood there without light it
wouldn't work if i'd stood there at all
i probably would have dissuaded the
animal from building so in that case yep
probably on the other hand
some of the species do build these
things in um
urban areas so it's possible that you
know in a in a village somewhere
bats building in a palm high up and up
above the ground might not have been as
disturbed
could have done it
but anyway to go back to the archbious
thing
before you continue so uh aj artibius
jamie census is uh described
uh
with particularly uh sort of juicy
detail bites ferociously when handled
yes which it does yes um yeah it's a
very this is the field notes for how to
identify what bad are you holding bites
ferociously when handled ah that'll be
the one then yep okay so
it's larger than the other tent makers
which is still like you know body size
is still very small i mean wingspan
yeah wingspan would be
six eight inches
um the uh
but so it's it's it's like the size of a
fist the animal's body it's a pretty
large animal and it's much so the thing
is the tent makers are all small this
one's conspicuously large and it doesn't
stick with a tent style
um all of which made me trans step
makers
well
it began it made me suspect something
was not right about this bat and then i
started to test that hypothesis
uh by looking at the data that other
people had taken on tents and the point
was there was no case in which this
animal had ever built a tent
had ever been observed to inhabit a tent
that was not also the species of plant
and the architecture of tent built by
some other animal in the same location
patrick yep yeah right so that
is a uh
is
strongly suggestive evidence then the
natural history observation is the
observation that a tent that i knew was
inhabited by another species was taken
over by artibius jimmy census proving
it's a thief
right so the point is that kind of
information
it doesn't prove it's only a thief but
um the circumstantial plus plus that
suggests that
and the fact that he doesn't look like
any other ten maggers right so all of
those things combined but the the point
is the one thing there that is um
more than just suggestive is the fact
that it is known at least in one case to
inhabit tents that were previously
inhabited by a different species so
anyway that's worthy of a note because
it means that anybody later on studying
these animals can at least say
well i'm starting from the knowledge
that sometimes artibia's jimmy census
does take over a tent from another
species yeah no it's it's a it's a it's
a first step it's a foundation on which
another research program could be built
and it's worthy of being shared this is
you know this is what
the scientific record is supposed to be
doing for us and instead it's
increasingly being filled with
garbage-y claims about people wanting an
alienating work environment as evidenced
by those who are making those claims
actually creating a
alienating environment for everyone yes
if exactly yeah feeling good about
themselves for doing so no i don't know
we can't
maybe
or just feeling like they're secure in
their jobs now that they have stood up
for the currently fashionable thing and
that's not what scientists are supposed
to be doing i'm supposed to be standing
up for the currently fashionable thing
right
yeah which actually connects the
feminism poster
to uh to science here because the right
to ignore fashion it should be an
obligation of scientists to ignore
fashion yeah i wonder if uh let's see if
we can change the scientists rather than
women the right to work the right ah it
doesn't really work the right to well
the right of the mother to her
profession doesn't really work but
scientists the right to their
convictions to their name to organ ah it
doesn't work never mind no it doesn't
work it depends what they've been
convicted of
yeah all right are we there i think so i
think we're there
okay
um
we
uh will come back for some more for some
more of this
in about 15 minutes for a live q a you
can ask your questions at uh
www.darkhorseadmissions.com we will get
to as many of them as we can beginning
with a question from the discord server
this week which you can find by joining
either of our patreons
there's other stuff to be had at our
patreons as well
you can if you've got logistical
questions about um things like hey i've
got a
thing i want to send to these people you
can email darkhorse moderator gmail.com
you should consider reading a hundred
gatherers guide to 21st century if you
haven't yet if you're enjoying the kinds
of conversations we have here and
be good to the ones you love
eat good food and get outside
check out the laboratory of the self and
take good data
[Music]
[Music]
you